Hello?
Telekom.
PC-Rib?
Nee, nicht PC-Rib.
Telekom-Internet abgekackt.
Lull.
Wisst ihr Leute, ich muss nie zur Telekom wechseln.
Kackladen, ähm.
Willst du eigentlich als Informatiker, was das Problem ist an meinem Internet-Dings?
Äh, was hast du für Probleme?
Was hast du für Probleme?
Ja, pass auf, folgendes.
Wenn ich streame, irgendwann, und letztens hab ich was gemerkt dadurch, irgendwann hab
ich Paketverluste.
Ungefähr drei Minuten lang.
Ja.
So.
Das liegt aber nicht an dir.
Und das aber jeden Tag, jeden Tag.
Ja, aber das liegt nicht an dir.
Ich mein, im Prinzip ist das...
Warte, warte, lass mich mal kurz zu weit erzählen, ne?
Ja.
Dann hab ich mir mal die Zeiten aufgeschrieben, und obvious ist halt, es ist, es scheint nicht
random zu sein, sondern es hat, es liegt dann irgendwas, und zwar, ähm, hab ich beobachtet,
ähm, einmal war es zum Beispiel 13.55 Uhr, und dann war es abends 19.55 Uhr.
Ja.
Heute war es auch wieder so random, zur gleichen Zeit.
Ja, ne, das liegt an deinem Provider.
Ich hab ja auch...
Echt?
Ich hab ja auch oft mal zwischen 17 und 19...
Aber jeden Tag?
Ja!
Wer weiß, was die da machen, das liegt nicht an dir.
Ähm, ich hab ja auch oftmals Disconnect zwischen 17 und 19 Uhr.
Einfach so, weil es der Telekom da da ist.
Die sind halt alle nicht mal in der Lage, ihren Scheiß richtig zu beherrschen.
Weil das ist nämlich extrem nervig, und die Leute müssen jetzt auch immer...
Es ist mega nervig.
Das pisst mich auch richtig an, wenn ich irgendwie mal auf streamen bin, und dann das Streamzustand
abkackt.
Bei mir ist es immer so, dann leckt mein Stream, keine Pakete werden mir gesendet, und dann
sag ich, Leute, in drei Minuten bin ich wieder da, und dann ist es so.
Ja.
Ja, bei mir dauert es auch zwei Minuten.
Dann verbindet sich das neu, und dann ist gut.
Das ist halt richtig räudig.
So.
Angeblich stehst du genau hier.
Aber du stehst hier gar nicht.
Warum steh ich dort?
Weil du ergeblich direkt da stehst auf meiner Map.
Ich bin unten am Beach.
Also laut meiner Map stehst du hier.
Wie ist das eigentlich, Leute, wenn man in diesen Loot sagt, nicht dieses Zeug hier annimmt,
tut das dann automatisch in sich Special Deals reinmachen?
Oder wie funktioniert das?
Aber mein Sound ist auch abgekackt.
Der Netz spielt zwei Jahre lang Black Desert, und ich hab keine Ahnung von Gruppengrind.
Ja, gut.
Das ist halt der Solo-Owner.
Ranger Grill.
Und auch vorher schon der Smeva Grill.
Smeva Grill.
Smeva Grill war OP, Mann.
Mahi war?
Ja, das war richtig OP, Mann.
Die Leute haben auch schon die Hoffnung aufgegeben.
Also entweder man lebt jetzt damit oder man quittet halt, aber das Ding wird sich nie ändern.
Ich frage mich, ob die in Korea das gleiche Problem haben.
Nee, wirklich, glaub ich.
Weil es könnte ja zwei Ursachen haben.
Entweder das Game ist technisch kacke, wo viele Sachen drauf hindeuten.
Hast du ein Problem?
Und Kakao kriegt sich auf die Reihe.
Oder halt gepaart, beides.
Ja, es ist gepaart und der Server steht wahrscheinlich in Hongkong irgendwo, in der Straßengasse,
wo die Hühner rumlaufen.
Weiß gar nicht, müssen wir mal gucken, wo die BDO Europa Server stehen.
Also Paris ist ja relativ beliebt, also Frankreich oder Irland.
Nee, ich glaube, die stehen wirklich so kacke, dass eben zum Beispiel bei mir, wo davon die Connection erlaubt
und ich immer mit VPN laden muss.
Und seit zwei Jahren mein Patch mit VPN laden.
Das ist aber glaube ich auch eher eine Sache von deinem Provider.
Ja eben, liegt doch an, wo da vorne gibt es so ein offizielles Topic im Forum drüber.
Dass die Patches aus Korea geladen werden, könnte ich noch verstehen.
Aber die spielen sie aber nicht in Korea, sonst hättest du ja da immer einen Ping von 250 oder so.
Du hast ja auch G-Sync und Ping von drei Millionen.
Aber kann man sich einen Ping anzeigen lassen in dem Game?
Nee, gar nicht, hab ich bloß gelabert.
Also ich geh mal davon aus, dass die schon EU Server haben, die auch irgendwo in EU stehen,
ist halt die Frage, wo, mit welcher Anbindung und was, was für Kisten sind.
Server stehen in Netherlands, schreibt jemand.
Niederlande, okay.
Okay, das ist, kenn ich jetzt sonst kein MMO, aber ist im Prinzip ist ja egal.
Die Frage, aber was macht das MMO aus, dass du mit Level 1 schon dein Endgame-Progression hast.
Also du kannst sofort bestimmen, was du machen willst und bist solo super effektiv.
Du bist ja nie angewiesen, irgendwelche Raids zu machen, brauchst kein bestimmtes Gear,
kannst schon mit Level 1 an Kohle machen, unterschiedlich viel natürlich.
Und du kannst jeden Tag, wenn du einloggst, dein Endgame bestimmen selber, was du machst.
Das ist halt geil, du bist nie gezwungen, heute muss ich meine Daily Dungeons machen oder sowas,
um Loot zu kriegen, sondern du kannst halt spielen, wie du willst.
Es ist halt nicht, und das find ich halt im Vergleich zu Final Fantasy sag ich jetzt mal gut,
es ist halt nicht so künstlich gecapped, wie das andere MMOs sind,
dass du in der Woche nur so und so viel Progress bzw. in der Woche nur so und so viel
Special Loot-Items machen kannst oder sowas.
Und du kannst halt spielen, wie du willst.
Du siehst, ich bin der übelste Noob in dem Game und steck nicht viel Zeit rein,
und ich kann das ganz gut spielen und der Fabian ist der 24-7-Krinder und der kann das auch gut spielen.
Und vor allem, es gibt halt auch für Leute wie mich, die gerne Spiele richtig suchten,
aber halt nur Ains.
Hier gibt es halt Motivationen, alle anderen MMOs, die ich da vorgespielt hab,
da war ich dann halt nach drei Monaten fertig und hab mir mit dem x-ten, 3-millionsten Schar
gelevelt und den Orner ausgestattet und dann gab es halt, es gab halt nichts weiter zu tun.
Und hier ist halt die Progression und auch das Items auf werden, das ist nahezu endlos,
es gibt immer was zu machen.
Man muss natürlich relativ frustresistent sein und darf halt nie so den typisch deutschen Lifestyle
fahren, wo man immer erwartet, alles in den Arsch geschoben zu kriegen.
Aber hier ist, macht schon Spaß seine Zeit hier zu wassen.
Vor allem, wenn man Grinden mag.
Wenn man Grinden mag, ist das, ist das Game echt nicht übel.
Und Lifeskills muss man natürlich sagen, ja, also das, wenn du WDO hast,
ist das eine der besten Berufe.
Crafting, ja.
Also das ist echt mega gut gemacht.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Wenn man Grinden gar nichts abgewinnen kann, ist das Game aber nicht das Richtige für einen.
Klar, du kannst zwar theoretisch schon andere Sachen machen, aber Grinden gehört schon dabei.
Ja gut, aber wenn du es jetzt so willst, so schnell wie das bis 60 geht jetzt,
also das muss man in Kauf nehmen und danach musst du auch nie wieder Grinden.
Du kannst doch komplett einen ganzen Tag Berufe machen.
Es ist gar nicht mehr so, dass du hier endless Grinden musst.
Du kannst halt deinen Content, das ist eben das, kannst deinen Content auf eine Stunde
Grinden am Tag beschränken oder noch weniger und den Rest machst du halt anderes Zeug.
Es gibt ja auch, sag ich mal, neben PVP und anderen Sachen gar nicht mehr so wenig zu machen.
Na vor allem, wenn du mal in diese Richtung gehst mit Node und Worker und sowas,
das kannst du ja theoretisch als komplett eigenes Game spielen innerhalb von dem Game.
Es gibt ja auch relativ viel, Nord.
Die Frage ist, die Leute machen es halt nie, weil es vielleicht nie so sinnvoll ist.
Ich meine, du kannst auch den ganzen Tag auf dem Schiff rumschippern
und die Leute wissen nicht immer, dass man zum Beispiel auf dem Meer draußen Piratenschiffe
ändern kann oder Wale jagen kann und sowas.
Aber Sagen haben nichts zu tun und haben noch nie irgendwie einen Drachen gejagt oder irgendwas.
Weißt du, wie ich meine?
Klar, du kannst dem Game schon viel machen.
Oder Tagswagen war wahrscheinlich die Hälfte der BDO-Community noch nie am Wochenende.
Wenn der Wagen irgendwie auf den Channels rumreitest und jeder versucht dort irgendwas aus dem Wagen rauszupassen.
Ich muss gleich zum Gaul.
Ist der Gaul so?
Ist der Gaul so.
Und ich muss mal was sagen zu dieser Quest-Grinden-Geschichte bzw. zur Grinden-Geschichte.
Ich sage immer, du grindest letztendlich in jedem MMO.
Also in jedem MMO, wo es um Slaven geht oder um XP machen, ist halt die Frage, was.
Im BDO grindest du halt Mops. Es gibt auch Quests.
Die machst du aber nicht unbedingt für XP.
Aber ob du jetzt einen MMO anfängst und dort quasi von Quest zu Quest rennst acht Stunden,
das ist halt auch nicht wirklich spannender als Mops im Kreis bashen.
Du kannst auch hier viele Quests machen.
Aber XP hast du halt am besten, wenn du Mops grindest.
Nie wirklich, außer du machst halt immer nur die Dailies bei den Mops-Spots.
Das gibt es ja jetzt überall bei den Level-Spots-Dailies, kannst du auch Quest machen.
Stimmt, wenn du das mitnimmst, klar.
Aber ich meine halt dieses normale Quest, wie du es von anderen MMOs kennst,
das machst du hier eher für Points.
Und das Kampfsystem ist halt geil, weil das Kampfsystem, ich kann ja mal kurz einblenden.
Oder auch nicht.
Das Kampfsystem ist halt so ein bisschen beat'em up-mäßig gemacht.
Du drückst nie wirklich deine Skills aus der Leiste.
Und davon lebt doch das Gehäuse.
Ich könnte den ganzen Tag grinden.
Du machst praktisch deine Skills von deinem Charakter über Kombos.
Über Tasten-Kombos. Und das macht es halt richtig geil.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal wieder hier hochschwimmen.
Alter, wie gerade schwimmt er, Wizard?
Oder besser nicht schwimmt.
Wizard.
Du könntest doch einfach dein Pferd hier vorne hinstellen.
Und hier durchs Ding durchschwimmen.
Ich bin Baywatch.
Na ja, es ist bedingt Pay2Win, Black Desert.
Du brauchst so eine gewisse Grundausstattung.
Aber es ist halt nie zu krass.
Also es geht schon.
Man kann es machen, ob man da nun ein Reward draus zieht oder nicht.
Hängt immer noch von deinem Glück ab.
Ich finde das Upgrade, auch wenn es immer viele sagen, ich finde das Upgrade-System echt in Ordnung.
Weil Leute auch mit diesem Upgrade-System auch aufschließen können.
Zwar nur wenn sie genug spielen oder vom RNG.
Moin, Mr. Dolphin.
Praktisch gebläst sind.
Aber im...
Also so gesehen, das beste Beispiel ist für mich der Streamer.
Joeyneverfails.
Das ist einer, der hat ganz spät angefangen.
Der spielt zwar auch 24-7, aber er spielt halt...
Oder Envy zum Beispiel.
Envy hat einen neuen Account.
Das ist halt für mich ein guter Beispiel, wie man da in kurzer Zeit Progress machen kann.
Dieser Joey-Typ zum Beispiel, der hat dieses Jahr erst angefangen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Monate her das ist, aber nie so weit.
Auf jeden Fall ist der Typ jetzt bei Level 62.
Der ist irgendwie Level 61 Striker, hat komplettes Softcap Gear.
Das ist so das beste Beispiel, wenn du weißt, was du machst.
Und natürlich sicherlich auch Glück hast und Zeit investierst, dass du hier locker aufschließen kannst.
Kannst natürlich nicht erwarten, dass du mit 5 Tagen Spielzeit komplettes TET Gear hast.
Aber das ist das beste Beispiel, wenn man sich...
Er wasert halt auch, nee.
Wo er gestartet hat, habe ich früher mal zugeguckt.
Er waste keine Stacks.
Er hat alles bedacht gemacht.
Und er hat halt so abgegradet, beziehungsweise so sein Zeug abgehaben.
So wie man das halt, wenn man sich mit dem Game beschäftigt.
Und das ist auch das Coulan Video.
Wenn man sich beschäftigt, kann man auch mit weniger Zeit hier viel erreichen.
Wenn man Sachen wasstet, dann natürlich nie.
Und das hat nie immer nur was damit zu tun, ob du successst oder nee.
Aber bei RNG ist es halt...
Nur mal so, umso mehr Versuche du machen kannst, umso öfter hast du eine Chance darauf, was zu kriegen.
Das heißt, wenn du deine Ressourcen sinnvoll investierst und 10 Versuche rauskriegst anstatt 3.
Genau.
Um es jetzt mal so rein Quick-Muffs zu machen, hast du halt Vorteile.
Naja, nee, halt eben nie unbedingt.
Also du hast dann daraus resultierend im Endgame Vorteile, sodass du eben Stacks hast.
Aber es gibt halt genug Leute, die wasten halt ihre Stacks.
Die wollen jetzt mal angenommen, die haben jetzt Zarka.
Wollen ihre Zarka jetzt 3 haben, so ungefähr.
Und dann werden dann halt so 45-50 Stacks für Duo genommen.
Und dann wird halt das nochmal gewaistet.
Dann bist du dann selbst dran schuld letztendlich.
Du bist ja aber selbst dran schuld.
Eben, deshalb ja.
Das liegt dann aber nicht an RNG, dass du Pech gehabt hast.
Du verkackst halt und machst halt nicht optimal.
Ja genau.
Das mehne ich auch immer wieder.
Man kann nämlich aus wenig auch viel machen.
Indem man nicht readies und sagt, jetzt will ich das unbedingt haben.
Sondern indem man halt wirklich gut mit den Ressourcen dann wirtschaftet.
Weil umso leichter, wenn das mit dem N-Item nicht funktioniert,
umso leichter hast du es dann vielleicht beim nächsten Item.
Weil du schon die entsprechenden Stacks aufgebaut hast.
Wie schaut es beim Klassenbilderchen aus?
Da kann ich wenig zu sagen.
Thomas, du hast zu sagen.
Warte mal, kurz als Beispiel.
Ich habe jetzt hier 34 Stacks, 35 Stacks.
Die nehme ich einfach nicht für Duo.
Weil das jetzt schon für Schmuck ist.
So kann man zum Beispiel wirtschaften.
Und ich habe jetzt gerade noch einen TET Nuva zu machen.
So mal als Beispiel, was ich meine.
Andere Leute würden jetzt halt die Stacks dafür nehmen,
um ihr Nuva Tri oder Duo zu machen.
Dann auf die 45er würden sie halt Tri machen.
Und dann vielleicht auf TET.
Aber am Ende hast du alle deine Stacks gerippt,
um halt auf einen Haufen nur zu failen.
Wisst ihr, wie ich mich erinnere?
Ich kann das schlecht erklären.
Das ist irgendwie...
Ich sehe es halt immer in Streams,
wenn dann die Leute einfach greedy sind
und jetzt unbedingt heute das Upgrade haben wollen.
Obwohl sie zum Beispiel noch Backup haben.
Wie bei Zarka zum Beispiel.
Die haben eine Tri Rosa oder eine Tri Liberto.
Da wird der ganze Progress auf das eine Item gedrückt,
um dann irgendwie 10 AP mehr zu haben.
Aber gerippt sind so krasse Stacks,
mit denen man so viel hätte machen können.
Es gibt ja auch Leute,
zumindest was man so liest,
ich habe ja dafür weder Gier noch irgendwie Material,
die dann anfangen quasi random alle ihre Items zu rippen.
Die dann anfangen so nach dem Motto,
hey, ich habe jetzt meine ganzen TET Items
und ich klicke jetzt alle durch.
Weißt du, wie ich meine?
Ja, das habe ich auch noch nie verstanden.
So, ich klicke jetzt alle durch in der Hoffnung,
ich kriege etwas und dann sind sie dann am Ende wieder so schlecht,
dass sie noch nicht mal an dem Spot,
wo sie vorher gekriden hat zum Geldmachen,
ordentlich kriden können.
Aber da kommt es halt immer drauf an, welche Voraussetzungen.
Wenn du genug Materialien hast,
kann man so ein Roulette schon machen.
Aber wenn du Chancen wieder hast hochzukommen, klar.
Aber wenn du es bis zuletzt dann machst,
dann hast du halt dann kacke Items.
Quick Muffs.
Muffs.
Aber Quick vor allem.
Wie sieht es mit Klassenbalancing aus?
Es ist so, BDO
weiß halt, wie man Leute melkt,
geldtechnisch.
Und meistens ist es so, dass die neuen Klassen,
die rauskommen, übersbroken sind.
Und auch alle neuen Klassen im Vergleich
zu den Baseklassen oder Vanillaklassen
oder wie man das auch immer sagen
wollte, relativ
strong sind.
Und es gibt definitiv
Klassen,
die halt wirklich
momentan schlecht
dastehen.
Aber eine Sache ist halt bei BDO
ganz cool.
Du weißt halt am Ende nie was kommt
und deshalb ist es eigentlich wurscht,
welche Klasse du spielst, weil
ab und zu wird halt eben mal was gepatcht
und dann kann aus deiner Trash-Klasse
instant eine Fottem-Klasse werden,
die halt richtig gut ist.
Oder besser ist.
Weißt du,
in welchem Game das noch so ist,
fällt mir gerade so ein.
In welchem Game das noch so ist,
dass die neuen Klassen oftmals total
OP sind, ist mir gerade so eingefallen.
Heroes of the Storm
ist das noch so.
Da war es auch total oft,
der letzte Held jetzt nicht unbedingt,
also was ich von Streams mitgekriegt habe,
ich gucke ja ab und zu mal Hot-Streams,
dass die neuen Helden immer
ziemlich gut gewesen sind.
Und in der Hoffnung,
die Leute stecken halt ein bisschen Kohle rein.
Das ist zum Beispiel ein
dummer Advice,
finde ich.
Sorg, wer kannst du Sorg spielen?
Spiel was du auf was du Bock hast.
Meine Skills auf Sorg sind ganz ok
und overall
ist es nicht so,
was definitiv Fakt ist, dass Klassen
direkt fallen gelassen werden.
Es ist zwar so, dass es sicherlich lange braucht,
bis es mal Upgrades gibt,
wie bei Musas, die 2 Jahre warten müssen
und immer ein bisschen besser werden,
aber es ist nicht so, dass die
sagen, ja,
ist uns alles scheißegal, es wirkt vielleicht
so, aber Leute,
ein Unternehmen
ist halt erstmal hauptsächlich auf Gewinn
raus und so
funktioniert nun mal die Welt.
Die Humber BDO hat jetzt ja auch nicht das riesen Team hinten dran.
Also das muss wohl
relativ klein sein.
Ich bin jetzt keiner, der
was schön redet,
aber die Leute, finde ich, fordern einfach
viel zu viel.
Es ist halt
ein bisschen zu
viel geheule manchmal.
Also ich finde den Balancing Ansatz, habe ich schon öfters
im Stream gesagt, finde ich den
Balancing Ansatz eigentlich gar nicht schlecht,
den sie in BDO machen. Das ist nicht so wie es in Overwatch
ist, dass da irgendwie ein Held am Start
ist, der total OP ist und beim
nächsten Patch, wo der Held geändert wird,
wird er halt in Grund und Boden genervt, das ist dann total
useless und scheiße. Ja gut, das gab es aber teilweise.
Ja, aber das ist ja, wenn du dir das mal bei Overwatch
anguckst oder teilweise in HotS, wenn es da
was neues rauskommt, sehr gang und gäbe.
Klar, du kannst nicht nur
durch verbessern der Helden sie auf ein
Level bringen, du musst auch manchmal Sachen, ein paar
Helden anpassen, die einfach gar so stark
sind, das musst du machen,
aber ich habe den Eindruck, die versuchen das Balancing
Ansatz eher darüber zu machen, dass die Helden,
die schlechter sind, eben
erstmal besser gemacht werden,
ohne die Helden, die halt OP sind,
jetzt
komplett zu beschneiden.
Ich meine, was haben sie
auch davon, wenn du deine Klasse so machst,
dass du keinen Bock mehr hast zu spielen,
du hast einen, der main die Klasse und sagt,
ne, jetzt habe ich keinen Bock mehr, ich spiele
jetzt nicht mehr, bis die Klasse wieder gut ist,
das schneiden sie sich als eigene Fleisch.
Ja.
Die cashen dann auch nicht mehr.
So sieht es aus.
Hier schreibt gerade jemand, wie lange braucht man denn
zu diesem Awakening?
Mir wurde gesagt, dass man erst
grinden muss um eine Klasse. Ja, grinden musst du so
oder so, also
am Anfang, also Level 60
wäre schon ein Ziel, was man machen sollte.
Je nachdem, was du für ein Spieler bist, wenn du
jetzt einfach nur so für dich vor dir her
spielst, dann musst du auch nicht
grinden, da ist Level 56 auf jeden Fall
Pflicht und das reicht dann auch erstmal.
Kommt halt drauf an, was du machen willst,
was so dein Content wäre.
Und
bis Level 56 brauchst du
nie lange. Die Frage ist aber
trotzdem, warum du jetzt
zum Beispiel fragst, wie lange was
dauert, weil wenn man ein MMO
spielt, will man ja eigentlich
lange spielen oder nicht? Du spielst
ein MMO, um nicht fertig zu werden.
Also das frage ich mich halt immer, die Mentalität
der Leute ist halt auch
komplett anders geworden. Also ein MMO, was du durchspielen kannst,
ist kein ordentliches MMO, so sehe ich das.
MMO muss immer
Sachen zu tun geben, sonst ist es
kein ordentliches MMO. Künstlich beschränkter
Progress ist auch für einen Arsch, weil die Leute, die
mehr spielen wollen, können nicht mehr spielen oder
müssen irgendeinen Scheiß machen, der ihnen nichts bringt.
Wie in Final Fantasy XIV.
Richtiges MMO darfst du nicht fertig werden.
Also finde ich halt auch so, das ist halt
keine Ahnung.
Aber ich bin halt auch, weißt
ich nicht,
über 34 und habe schon so viele
MMOs mitgenommen und früher habe ich
MMOs gespielt, weil ich einfach
weil ich einfach stundenlang irgendein
Game zocken wollte. Und immer
was zu tun haben wollte. Und das war das Problem
für mich persönlich immer bei den
alten MMOs halt.
Das war so langweilig ey.
Und dann bist du zum nächsten nach drei Monaten
so ein typischer MMO-Hopper.
Weil was willst du denn auch machen?
Wir haben ja, was haben wir denn
alles, also wir haben, lass mal überlegen.
Was haben wir denn alles gespielt? Wir haben natürlich am Anfang
Dark gespielt, wir haben ein bisschen
Terra-Beta gespielt, wir haben Rift.
Rift haben wir gespielt. Damals relativ
viel gespielt.
Rift haben wir sogar relativ viel gespielt
bis irgendwie dann halt
bis wir keinen Bock mehr hatten.
Beziehungsweise wir haben es nie bis Max-Level
gespielt, aber am Anfang relativ
viel. Du hast ja dann festgestellt, aber es
sackt. Guild Wars 2.
Tezo hast du gespielt, da habe ich schon
die Beta ein bisschen gespielt.
Tezo habe ich gespielt, Guild Wars 2, ja.
Was haben wir noch?
Ich habe halt
dann so einen Haufen zwischendrin
so Koreanagrinder MMOs
gespielt oder so ähnlich Diablo
Zeug. Wir haben Palmer Dark
auf irgendwie so viele Shards gespielt.
Willian zum Beispiel habe ich nebenbei, aber das waren die wirklich
das war irgendwie MMO, aber irgendwie
auch nicht. Wir haben jetzt
wir müssen noch irgendwas vergessen haben.
Ich meine es sind trotzdem
immer noch relativ viele. Aber dann so ein Scheiß
WoW halt.
Lavau habe ich im Karsten ein bisschen gespielt.
Ja, hast du im Karsten gespielt.
Ich habe nie mitgespielt.
Die meisten großen MMOs
haben wir durch. Ich muss sagen, für mich
ist nie wieder ein MMO.
Gut, ich meine, die Spiele mit denen du anfängst
ist meistens so, dass du sagst, hey, das waren die geilsten.
Aber ich bin der Meinung, Dark
war für seine Zeit und auch
lange noch danach das beste MMO.
Und es gibt da
ich habe eigentlich, obwohl wir viele MMOs
durchprobiert haben, haben wir nie so was
gefunden, wo wir gesagt hätten, hey, hier fühlst du dich
irgendwie so halt wohl und zuhause
wie es in Dark war.
Außer bei dir jetzt halt in BDO.
Ich meine die Dinge,
die wir früher gespielt haben.
Also ich muss schon sagen, so Welttechnisch
und alles, ich feier das Game
richtig ab. Wenn es halt ein bisschen besseres
Swesterbalancing geben würde.
Aber es ist halt immer so in MMOs
eine Sache. Aber da der Content
im BDO halt so
solo bezogen ist,
vergleicht man halt natürlich auch die
Klassen solomäßig. Früher
hätte zum Beispiel in Dark
hätte keiner was über Balancing gesagt,
weil Sork jetzt zum Beispiel Damage,
C10 und so weiter konnte.
Weißt du, da war er auch so.
Ja gut, es wurde schon, in den
deutschen Foren nicht, da war er auch nur
in den englischen Foren, da wurde er schon
übelst rumgeflamt über manche Sachen.
Ja, es wurde über die Kombination
geflamt, aber an sich,
da ist auch so, guck mal, da ist auch so
Klassen raus, wie Mystic zum
Beispiel. Wie kann so was
entstehen? Das ist total krass.
Das ist so broken einfach.
Wie können die Leute,
nachdem sie die anderen
Klassen, so wie Sork oder Vary
rausbringen, wie können die dann solche
Klassen wie Mystic, wisst ihr nicht, einfach mal
dein Pferd hier herrufen, Max? Kann ich mal machen.
Ich glaub, der immer runter zu rennen und
hoch zu schwimmen.
Wie kommt man hier am besten hoch, eigentlich?
Auf der Seite.
Ich jump jetzt. Ja, einfach außen lang schwimmen
oder hier. So rum, ne, ich mach jetzt so.
Weil du kannst halt hier unten direkt durchlaufen, dann.
Pfff, what?
Auf, komm her.
Das ist der Friseur,
der da spricht, ja.
Ich streame auch.
Er streamt auch. Ausrufe,
Zeichen, Fabian im Chat, danke.
Echt? ETF, ich hab einen eigenen
Comment von mir. Du hast, du hast einen Bot-Comment
von mir, ja. Lul.
Aber du willst ja, du verwendest ja
keine Bots.
Also außer, außer, ja,
für Gier, ich weiß. Ja, das reicht.
Ansonsten hast du ja nichts angestellt.
Und das ging mir übelst auf den Sack, mein ganze Chat war voll.
Ich hasse dieses Bot-Zeug eigentlich.
Man muss es halt ordentlich machen.
Ne, auch mit Delay und so,
dass man nur alle so und so viel, es nervt mich trotzdem.
Mir ist kein Bot-Spam.
Ja, weil es auch uninteressant
ist, weil was willst du denn bei Overwatch gucken?
Die Leute kommen, das siehst du auch hier,
die Leute kommen rein, tippen Gier. Genau.
Wenn du auch einen Comments hast, skilletons, zack.
Ja, das hab ich ja nicht so aus.
Weißt du, wie viele Leute am Tag reinkommen und einfach random machen
bei BDO, einfach Gier und so was
klicken? Ja.
Ich bin ja ein Bot bei dir
und ich krieg immer Nachricht, wenn einer bei dir
in einem Video was kommentiert.
Ja, weil
du musst ja moderiert werden
und du glaubst nicht, in wie vielen Wots bei dir die Leute
in Gier schreiben.
Siehst du immer, hat einen Nachricht
hinterlassen
unter einem Video von einem Kanal, den du moderierst.
Bam, Gier.
Vor allem in irgendeinem Wot,
weil der Bot dann auch antwortet.
Also ich glaub, ich mach noch bis 23 Uhr
und dann guck ich schon ein bisschen Overwatch.
Das ist Quatsch, SpawnCamp.
Als Neuling sollte man einfach
eine andere Klasse als Wattel.
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz drauf eingehen.
Neuling sollte man einfach eine andere Klasse als Sorc wählen.
Bin selbst neu und habe eine Sorc gemacht.
Da würde ich niemandem neu raten,
eine andere Klasse
zu wählen.
PvP um Greinsmotz, siehst du halt kein
Land, wenn du nicht das über Gier hast.
Das ist totaler Quatsch.
Als ob du, pass auf,
als ob du, wenn du dir jetzt zum Beispiel Witch Wizard machst
und dann eine Sorc machst,
weil dich die Klasse interessiert, bessere
Sorc Spieler bist. Das ist total Quatsch.
Im WDO sollte man
den Char, den man noch spielen will,
einfach spielen. Das ist nicht so wirklich
sinnvoll, den nicht zu spielen,
weil wie willst du denn besser werden?
Und vieles ist ja auch geht gut, sag ich mal so.
Gut, bei Sorc
kommt es halt immer drauf an.
Aber wie willst denn du
besser werden, wenn du die Klasse
nicht spielst? Und
das mit Gier ist bei allen anderen
Klassen genau das gleiche.
Ich finde das
totaler Schwachsinn.
Zumal
im PvE eine Sorc
relativ gut ist, also selbst mit
schlechten AP, dann spätestens dann mit
Awakening. Dann gibt es
weitaus schlechtere Klassen.
Welche Klasse willst du denn spielen?
Welche weniger Gier brauchst, damit du die
Leute vom Spot killst? Also keine Ahnung.
Da lebst du, da lebst du
in der Traumwelt.
Das Problem hast du mit jeder Klasse.
Wizard Beste.
Äh, wo bist du?
Dann verstehe ich deine Argumentation
nicht. Da sagst du, Sorc sei super
stark, wenn
den nur ein, was? Gott, die Tastatur
bedient.
Ja, es gibt ja auch einfache
Klassen. Das ist ja nicht der Punkt.
Aber du kannst doch nie, du kannst doch
nie direkt zu jemandem sagen,
spiel keine Sorc. Das macht gar keinen Sinn.
Wenn du natürlich diese
typische Mentalität...
Nun geht er ab.
Jetzt geht er ab.
Ups.
Eigentlich wollte ich nur mich muten.
Wenn dir Spaß geht und dich eine Klasse
interessiert, warum sollte man
dann den Striker oder Witch Wizard spielen?
Das ist doch der Punkt.
Klar gibt's...
Ja, gibt's gerade Klassen, die am Anfang
einfacher sind, aber wie gesagt,
wenn du Sorc spielen willst,
dann spielt man sie, weil vom nicht spielen
wirst du keine bessere Sorc.
Wie soll denn das gehen?
Als, also jetzt, also bitte
Spawn Cam. Jetzt tut man die
so, als wäre Sorc die schlechteste
PvE Klasse, die es gibt, man.
Und ich weiß auch nie,
was die Leute immer mit ihren Grindspots
haben. Manche tun so, als wären sie
24-7 abgefarmt überall.
Dann muss man vielleicht halt auch mal was anderes
außer sausen und
Pirates machen.
Ich hab das noch nie verstanden.
Das ist wie die Fischer, die
Fischen, die sich immer beschweren, dass sie jeden Tag
zwanzigmal gekillt werden.
Also ich bin Master 22
beim Fischen und wurde noch nie beim Fischen gekillt.
Selbst außerhalb von
Safe Zones.
Auf so Fragen geht er immer ab.
Ich wurde einmal gekillt
und dann wird man schnell zwanzigmal draus gemacht.
No Happy Meal for you,
feels bad man.
Ich lasse ihn fahren, wenn er es erst mal
in Ruhe beantworten.
Trigger intensifies.
Also ich mach noch 10 Minuten,
Leute. Bis 23 Uhr.
Guck schon ein bisschen auf, aber was wir kennen.
Das muss auch nicht unbedingt so sein.
Inui.
Wenn man mit westlichen MMOs
groß geworden ist,
ich hab nur westliche MMOs
gespielt.
Zum größten Teil und das halt mehrere Jahre.
Und weißt du, was ich in westlichen MMOs
gemacht hab, statt zu questen?
Ich hab sinnlose Trashmops
gegrindet, weil ich Grinden schon
immer gefeiert hatte. Ich glaube, das ist eher
die Präferenz, ob man
grinden mag oder nicht, weil das ist auch
der inche Punkt, dass es keine Dungeons gibt.
Und dass man halt grinden muss
fürs Leveln, statt Herzchenquests
zu machen.
Und da kann man dann sagen, gut, wenn man jetzt
Mops abschlachten will
und man das feiert,
dann gibt es gar keinen Grund,
die, sag ich mal, nicht zu
zu mögen, meiner Meinung nach.
Ich finde, das kann man auch gar nicht so genau
einteilen, westliche und
nicht westliche MMOs, sondern eher in
WoW abklatschen und nicht
WoW abklatschen. Also klar, natürlich gibt es
Unterschiede zwischen MMOs, die hauptsächlich
wenn du siehst, allein schon optisch,
ja, Asia MMOs und sowas,
kennst du von. Aber
das war früher bei MMOs,
sagen wir mal so, die vor WoW raus
gekommen sind, war das ganz normal,
dass du da auch gegrindet hast.
Das war vollkommen normal. Das hat erst mit WoW
angefangen, so diese Questhub-Geschichte.
Weißt du, wo du in eine Stadt gehst, hast
einen NPC, redest mit dem NPC, der NPC
schickt dich zum nächsten NPC. So richtig
angefangen hat das erst mit WoW. Davor
waren alle MMOs gewisserweise
grindlastig.
Guck mal,
wie lange haben wir den Daug rumgegrindet?
Ewig!
Eigentlich auch. Das war ja auch ein
westliches MMO,
in diesem Sinn.
Das sind diese ganzen
Quest-MMOs, sind halt so diese
WoW
abklatsch-Dinger, die halt
das machen wollen, was
WoW gemacht hat.
Weißt du noch, als ich mit dir Guild Wars 2
gespielt hat, du hast permanent rumgeheult wegen
Herzenquests. Und da muss ich dir
auch recht geben, es war halt sinnlos.
Das fanden aber alle geil
an Guild Wars 2. Ich fand das auch richtig
ekelhaft. Das haben alle sich drüber gefreut
als das erste Addon in Guild Wars 2 rausgekommen
ist, haben sich drüber aufgeregt, so nach
dem Motto, das ist doch kein Guild Wars mehr,
hier gibt es keine Herzenquests.
Herzenquest war der schlimmste überhaupt.
Du bist einfach über die Map gelaufen, hast ein paar
tauslose Mobs gebashed und bist weiter
zum nächsten, das war so schlimm.
Das war echt das schlimmste MMO.
Das war richtig. Mir hat Guild Wars 2 überhaupt
nicht gefallen.
Ich fand WoW damals, ich habe
hier zu Release gespielt, da war das ja
noch was anderes. Ich habe
WoW gespielt, da war es halt geil, wo
alle noch PvP gemacht haben, dann habe ich
ja irgendwann dieses letztes Jahr mal
wieder reingeguckt, war in WoW
mit meinem Ranger.
Weißt du wie das WoW aussah?
Ja, ich weiß, die
sprechen sich ab, wo und so.
Gegenseitig die Dinger
für EXP geradet, da
ist kaum mal ein Fight zustande gekommen.
Keiner PvP.
Das war so dumm, dachte ich mir, okay,
nee. SPVP ist natürlich wieder
was anderes, ne Leute?
Aber wenn ich sowas
wie SPVP spielen will, dann spiele ich
ein MOBA, kein MMO.
Ich will, dass es skiabhängig ist,
ich möchte mein Charakter ausstatten,
damit ich dann dem SPVP
ein MOBA spiele, so ungefähr.
Außerdem nimmt es auch viel Taktik raus, ja?
Was wäre, was wäre Dark PvP gewesen,
ohne Template bauen?
Ja, was hier ist Taktik? Du baust ja dort
auch ein Template zusammen, ne?
Beim SPVP ist natürlich immer das Problem,
dass es halt pro
Patch halt immer ein bestimmtes Meta gab
und am Ende war es auch nie so vierseitig,
weil eh alle nur Meta-Setup
geradet sind, wie zum Beispiel
Bunker.
BoF.
Was ist das?
Du hast es verstanden,
sonst hat es keiner verstanden.
BoF ab, BoF bester.
Source.
Welche Stufe? Drei.
Muss.
Ähm, deshalb das,
was Sava da geschrieben hat, finde ich
halt ganz nice, würde ich nicht unterschreiben,
habe auch Norwesnische gespielt.
Finde BDO klasse, ist eher die Frage
der Erwartungshaltung, die meisten wollen
halt immer von Tag eins, am besten
täglich Level up und hier und und und
das halt, genau so sehe ich es
halt auch und das ist halt der Hauptpunkt,
warum Leute halt
quitten, weil die typische Spielementalität
und wie man es gewöhnt ist, es ist nie so,
dass man, wer, wer, wer
kennt das von MMOs, dass man wochenlang
für irgendeinen Slot farmt,
ne? Das nächste Geld, zum Beispiel bei
mir jetzt, das ist wochen- und monatelang
für drei AP so.
In welchem Spiel gibt es das schon?
In anderen MMOs müsste
ich jetzt zwanzigmal den Dungeon raiden
mit meiner festen SG und hätte mein Gier
zusammen und darf auf Snakeside on warten.
Ob ihn das nur motiviert oder ne?
Das ist halt eine andere Frage, mich motiviert
das, ich kann immer weitermachen und selbst wenn
ich alles getät hab, dann geht's los mit Penn
und ich hab immer Bock zu spielen, aber
das, das ist halt nichts,
ich sag mal so, das ist halt nichts für
für faule Leute so
oder die, für die Leute,
die einen Easy-Weg gehen, ne?
Oder sag ich mal, einfach das nie bevorzugen, wie bei dir
jetzt Max, ne? Du bist ja auch der, du würdest
dir jetzt hier nie den Arsch abgrinden, um
irgendwelches Gier zu machen.
Ich brauch halt irgendwie den Ziel vor Augen, ne? So 60
und sonst was. Aber so ein bisschen
Grind hab ich nix.
Also mir ist Grinden am liebsten
von der, von, von
Level Progression ist mir Grinden
am liebsten allerdings
nicht Solo-Grind, sondern am liebsten
Gruppen-Grind. Ja.
Der wird gebashed werden, glaub ich.
Ja, ja.
Der Level den
Law-Typen.
Der hilft nur jemandem.
Übrigens, ich mach bis 23 Uhr noch,
dann reicht's. Ja.
Kann ich dann
gatheren gehen, mein Freund? Kannst gatherer.
Bist du morgen am Start?
Oder musst L stellen? Morgen
ja, also so ein Zwischending
eher.
Können wir morgen Abend noch mal ne Runde Kreisel
grinden. Ja. Also ich, ich kann morgen
nie sagen, wann ich am Start bin.
Kannst du das ganz einfach im Discord Bescheid sagen.
Ja. Easy
Clap. Easy
TTS.
Du musst dir übrigens noch
ein paar wichtige Better Dridge TV Emotes
mal aktivieren im Channel. Warum?
Ja, es gibt ein paar Emotes, die braucht man.
Also ohne MonkaS geht's zum Beispiel gar nichts.
Und
Easy Clap ist eigentlich auch sehr angesagt zur
Zeit.
Easy Clap
mach ich mir nie. Easy Clap find ich nicht. Da macht
ihr mindestens MonkaS und am besten MonkaX.
Dann
haben wir schon mal so die
essentiellen Sachen. Ich hab ja, ich benutze ja zur
Zeit nicht immer Better Dridge TV, ich bin ja so ein Clap.
Ja, aber die Leute, die gucken, benutzen.
Also du musst ja nicht benutzen,
dass die Leute, wenn du es freigeschaltet hast,
verwenden können die Emotes.
Ja.
Ist das
Game gut besiedelt, was Spielerzahl angeht?
Ja. Also mittlerweile,
ich muss gerade mal gucken.
Also ich darf sagen, dass es eine der
meistgespielten MMOs so zur Zeit
mit. Und das wird auch
im Gegensatz zu anderen MMOs,
irgendwie lag das. Ja,
lag übelst rum. Im Gegensatz zu anderen MMOs
wird BDO
meiner Meinung nach
mindestens noch bis
mehr Spielerzahlen
als weniger haben. Normalerweise ist es ja so,
dass die Spielerzahlen eher abfallend ist.
Bei BDO ist eindeutig der Trend,
dass vielleicht die alten Veteranen
aufgrund der Desings und Lags irgendwann
keinen Bock mehr haben, weil PvP bleibt halt
irgendwie gleich laggy und die Server
werden nie wirklich erst gemacht, aber so
von Interesse der Leute.
Du merkst halt eindeutig, dass
immer wieder Zuwachs kommt. Und vor allem,
was auch ganz klar zu merken ist,
die Leute, die halt so
dieses typische Burnout haben
in BDO und dann zurück
zu ihren MMOs gehen,
was weiß ich, WoW oder was weiß ich, die kommen
halt alle irgendwo wieder. Also
die meisten zumindest. Hast du eigentlich absichtlich
gefleckt? Ja.
Ich hab den gekillt. Aber weißt du,
die besten MMOs
hatten
langsam, haben langsam aber
stetischen Zuwachs.
Das hast du in DAW gesehen und das hast du letztendlich
auch in WoW irgendwie gesehen. In WoW
war es noch auf einer ganz anderen Ebene.
WoW hatte von Anfang an einen riesen Hype und viele Spieler.
Allerdings hat sich dann auch rumgesprochen,
das Game ist wirklich gut und es haben noch
viel mehr angefangen.
WoW war auch so ein
Spieleportal,
wo sich was halt jeder
gespielt hat. Zum Beispiel meine Schwester
und ihr Mann haben das gespielt. Das sind die
eigentlich richtigen Randoms. Weißt du wie? WoW?
Oder was?
Ja, meine Schwester hat WoW gespielt.
Die spielt keine
Spiele. Die spielt aber WoW.
Weiß ich nicht warum.
Aber da kamen ja die ganzen
Reportagen so.
WoW war für viele ja wirklich das erste.
Leute, Heike
und Kai spielen täglich
20 Stunden WoW.
Oh mein Gott.
Wir haben sie in ihrer Wohnung
in Berlin besucht.
Der alltägliche Morgen startet mit einer
Tasse Kaffee. Danach wird der PC angemacht.
Und dann kommt der Assi-Tony. Es muss klatschen, Alter.
Es muss klatschen. Heike und
Heike und Karsten... Nee, was
hab ich gesagt? Egal.
Heike und Karsten treffen sich
mit Philipp zu einem Raid. So waren
die Reportagen
über WoW. Das weißt du, dass du richtig retardet
und dass sie einfach noch gedacht, Alter!
Er hat hier zwei Hobbys los
oder von wo-rimmer das war.
Am besten haben sie dann immer noch,
wenn sie dann so Dinger gesagt haben, so
blablabla, das kostet viel
Zeit und Arbeit. Wie im echten Leben.
So ist es so in der Richtung.
Auch ihr 16-Jähriger,
so ein Felix
spielt WoW. Er spielt eine
Nachtelfe oder irgendwas
so was ist. Und dann
müssten sie noch das Video zeigen von dem Typ, der
sich da vom Rechner eingefappt hat zur Nachtelfe.
Das ist wieder mal
ein Bauvideo.
Und dann haben sie immer solche...
Dann haben sie immer solche...
Na, solche...
Die Typen dann moderiert.
Und dann so gesagt. Und dann hat der
Felix dann von seiner Nachtelfe erzählt.
Ja, am besten finde ich an WoW
die Quests.
Und dass ich mit meinen Freunden große
Monster raiden kann.
Und letztendlich ist es auch für wirklich
viele Leute genau das gewesen.
Die konnten zusammen spielen mit Leuten.
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen,
dass ein riesen Teil von MMOs
neben dem eigentlichen
MMO-Gameplay so auch so diese soziale
Komponente ist.
Das ist einfach ein riesen Faktor bei MMOs,
der immer wieder übersehen wird,
dass man auch MMOs
sind prinzipiell
zu 50% MMO
und zu 50% Chat-Simulator,
wenn du so willst. Also 50%
Chat und 50%
der Rest so.
Guck mal, wie viele Leute, die
in der Gilde sind und sonst was in MMOs,
loggen ein,
haben eigentlich gar nicht so wirklich Bock
zu spielen, stehen dann einfach rum,
machen irgendwas, craften irgendwas,
gucken einfach nur rum, sitzen irgendwie rum,
sind aber im Guilden-Chat am Start.
Das sind sau viele MMOs so.
Deswegen
ist doof. Aber das ist auch nur so,
das kann ich hier sagen. Also das ist
nur so, ist so schlimm in anderen BDOs,
äh in anderen MMOs.
Und das ist der
Faktor, wird oft in dem Spiel hier
vergessen, dass
du meistens in den anderen Spielen
kaum eine Möglichkeit hast,
einfach einzuloggen
für eine Stunde und was zu
machen. Dann ist klar, dass alle
im Chat socialisen und in der Stadt
rumstehen. Wissen wir, wie ich meine?
Und der Vorteil, der größte Vorteil
daran, die Leute, die anfangen, neu,
du brauchst halt hier niemanden.
Es ist zwar irgendwo schade, aber wenn du
wenig Zeit hast, du musst dich nie mit
irgendwelchen Leuten verabreden, um hier
Kontern zu machen. Das stimmt. Du loggst ein.
Wenn du 20 Minuten hast, kannst du 20
Minuten effektiv nutzen. Und das
war in game MMOs außer vielleicht
craft in der Fall. Wenn du nur 20
Minuten Zeit hast, kannst du in 20 Minuten
grinden und grind ist halt progress.
Und das ging halt oder das geht
in MMOs nur bedingt. Und hier,
egal wie du die Zeit investierst,
du kannst halt sinnvoll nutzen und stehst
halt nie drei Stunden irgendwo und
musst dir halt ne Crypt suchen oder brauchst
dieses und jenes und dann ist noch
jemand essen und dann verschiebt sich das
einfach nur. Aber in anderen MMOs
haben sie das so
durch so ne Krücke behoben, in dem sie Dungeon
Finder eingeführt haben und sowas. Also quasi
MMOs, die auf Gruppencontent
ausgelegt sind und irgendwie halt auch
so dieses socialisen und
Gruppencontent bieten, wurde quasi
genau das Gegenteil davon eingeführt,
nämlich Dungeon Finder, was da dazu führt.
Das stimmt, aber Dungeon Finder bedeutet natürlich
wie immer, dass du dann auch Spaß hast.
Nö, überhaupt nicht.
Wenn wir einen scheiß Tank hatten oder so.
Du hast Dungeon Finder, ist das Gegenteil von Spaß.
Du spielst mit Randoms von
anderen Servern, die du nie wieder siehst, was
dazu führt, dass die Leute gar nicht reden,
übelst toxik rumspacken oder sonst was.
Das war ja gerade bei
MMOs, wo es halt auch darum ging,
dass du auf dem Server gespielt hast
und dich da untereinander gekannt hast,
da hat sich das jeder zweimal überlegt,
ob er da jetzt irgendwie
halt den übelsten Spaß
raushängen lässt.
Weil im Zweifelsfall hat er Pech gehabt,
es hat ihn keiner mehr mitgenommen, was bei Dungeon
Finder ja nicht mehr so ist.
Also ich finde Dungeon Finder ist eines der
spielerfeindlichsten Sachen,
die jemals in MMOs eingebaut wurden.
Und ohne dass man es so richtig merkt, eigentlich
sieht man sich da am Anfang erstmal geil, kann ich mir
Content machen, muss mir mal Grip suchen.
Aber es wird einfach ein ganz großer
Aspekt von MMOs damit
ausgeklammert. Ich bin aber auch
kein Fan von Dungeon Finder. Deswegen finde
ich es hier gut, dass sie es so gemacht haben.
Es ist eine konsistente Spielwelt und
du kannst halt auch alleine was machen. Du musst
nicht in Gruppe was machen und deswegen Dungeon Finder.
Das finde ich gut.
Und ich sag mal so, ich meine die lernen
natürlich auch draus und die nächsten
Content Sachen, die gern auch
ein kleines Mühe Gruppenfokus
sein. Das sieht man schon am Kamaz 2
Spot, dass das
halt momentan der beste Progression
Spot für Exp und Geld
ist. Für Gruppe
und ich meine sowas
wird es auch geben. Das
ist vielleicht am Anfang ziemlich
hardcore gewesen, aber
momentan ist
sie denken ja auch um und nie umsonst
wird BDO halt auch immer einfacher
gemacht.
Solange die nie alles versauen ist
alles gut.
So meine
Rucksack ist voll
Stelzen. Fertig
mit Stelzen. Kein Bock mehr hier.
Ich geh jetzt zum Gaul, lade es rein.
Bzw. ne, ich lade es raus
auf den kleinen Wizard drauf.
Der kleine Wizard.
Und dann muss ich mal gucken wie wir hier runtergeritten
kommt gescheit. Was passiert
eigentlich wenn das Pferd ins Wasser fällt?
Nix mehr. Früher ist es
gestorben, aber jetzt glaube ich nichts mehr.
Man kann es ja auch schlau machen
und einfach hier hoch rufen.
Ja, eigentlich schon.
So,
reiten wir mal in die Stadt
Leute und dann gucke ich noch ein bisschen
auf Overwatch.
Und ich stream noch weiter.
Gessern,
gestern streamt. Gessern und
ich glaube noch ein bisschen RBF.
Lass mich ein bisschen triggern.
Ja,
ich bin schon ein bisschen
aufgewachsen.
Ja, ich bin schon ein bisschen
Du kannst dich von den Musas weg
Chargen lassen.
Sind da wirklich so viele jetzt?
Eigentlich stirbt, das Pferd stirbt
doch nicht mehr, oder? Echt?
Stirbt es jetzt doch?
Ich dachte immer, jetzt können die Pferde
einfach, ach, eine Minute Zeit, okay.
Solange war mein Pferd noch nie unter Wasser.
Also das wusste ich nie.
Eine Minute unter Wasser. Wie holt man das Pferd raus,
oder was? Okay. Pfeifen, ne?
Oh.
So, fake. Ich muss mal gucken, ob überhaupt
noch Overwatch läuft.
Ich reite hier völlig
beschissen. Sehe ich gerade.
Overwatch schlägt hier.
Brainlex des Todes gerade.
Ich bin halt immer noch so ein
Wegereiter. Ich reite immer quer durch
die Prärie.
Ich reite afk.
Afk.
Das dauert mir zu lange.
Overwatch läuft noch. Ja, ich weiß, es läuft gerade
das erste Game. Ich hab da abgeguckt.
Ja, ich muss sagen, ich seh es gehört
bei dir aus.
Ja, ich muss sagen, ich seh es gehört bei dir
im Chat. Irgendjemand hat gerade so was geschrieben, wie
Raids sind kacke. Also ich muss
sagen, ich bin auch kein
großartiger Fan von
Instance Raids.
Das ist ein Konzept, das fand ich nie so
toll, weil
die meisten Sachen musst du ja gefühlt
200 mal machen.
Und egal wie gut ein Raid
designed ist, das ist
nach dem 20. Mal langweilig.
Das ist, du kannst
kein Raid so geil designen, dass das beim
200. Mal auch Spaß macht. Vielleicht
den 200. Mal übertrieben. Aber es ist halt dann auch nichts anderes als
Kreiselgrinden. Es ist im Prinzip auch
nicht viel anders als Kreiselgrinden.
Und gerade so dieses instanzierte, dass da machst
du dann quasi, wenn es zwei Endgame Dungeons gibt
oder vielleicht sogar nur ein Endgame Raid,
dann machst du dann drei Wochen den gleichen Scheiß jeden
Tag. Und teilweise
manche Raids dann irgendwie 5 Stunden oder so,
wie es früher gewesen ist. Also ich,
diese ganze Instance Raid-Geschichte
fand ich noch nie sonderlich tolle.
Ich meine,
selbst wenn du Open World
Dungeons hast,
die sind dann zwar nicht spannender,
aber da kannst du im wenigstens durchzehren
mit 80 Leuten und
dabei Livestream gucken oder so.
Oh, oh,
der unabmerksame Healer.
Deswegen der ganze Raid.
Ich weiß noch, wo du in Dark
denkst, wie hieß diese Epic Dungeon
in Alp? Weißt du auch
das auf dem Berg da oben drauf?
Ja, ja, genau. Da habe ich
gestickt und 4 Stunden später bin ich wieder gekommen
und dann hänge ich an dieser einen Leiter dran.
Ah, das war schon was.
So Leute, ich mache mal meinen Stream aus.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen. War jetzt recht spontan eine Geschichte.
Vielleicht grinden wir morgen noch eine Runde.
Ich mache jetzt von mir aus.
Macht's gut bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss. Genau.
Macht's gut bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Tschüss.